but first the prime minister says that a
new variant of covid is causing cases to
spread more quickly and the christmas
plans have to be cancelled
to avoid the nhs being overwhelmed so
how much of a threat does the new strain
pose to hospitals where we'll ask that
question now to
the bma's chair of council dr chand
nadpal thanks very much for coming with
us
uh today so the prime minister said
yesterday hospitalizations are rising
in london the south east and the east of
england what are you seeing
well today we've just uh published the
results of a major
survey of doctors experiences uh in the
nhs
over the last week and it in fact paints
a really bleak picture
doctors are saying they're overwhelmed
they've seen a massive surge
in covet cases one in three saying even
more
than during the first wave but also a
massive surge in non-coveted patients so
that
they're actually saying they don't have
the capacity the ability
to manage both and 1910 say they're not
able to provide patients with the care
they need now you know last week there
were 44 patients who had to be re-routed
away from their local hospital to more
remote sites because the hospital just
didn't have the capacity
to meet their urgent needs two hospitals
in london
declared a critical incident which
occurs when a hospital
feels it cannot manage acute and
critical care
that it's being asked to provide so this
is a serious condition
situation a situation that can only be
helped
if we can reduce the numbers of covet
patients
that are occupying hospital beds we've
seen a massive increase i think nearly
about
one in five extra beds occupied with
coveted patients over the last week
what i don't understand though is that
the nightingale hospitals that we built
during the first wave
are effectively still on standby why
don't we just increase capacity if it's
needed
i think the biggest limiting factor is
workforce
uh because we have got unfortunately we
entered the pandemic with a shortage
of doctors and nurses i think about 80
000 vacancies in the nhs
you you just can't have a doctor or
nurse in two sites at once
so so what what's probably better is to
try and make sure that
we have as many drops than nurses
available on single sites
to be able to provide care remember it
isn't just about covert patients
there are large numbers of patients who
do not have covid
that also needs to be looked after they
can also have urgent needs whether it's
cancer
whether it's heart attacks or other
acute respiratory conditions
that we see in the winter so let's not
forget their needs
too and that's the problem we had in the
first wave we had i think
around 12 000 excess deaths because
patients without covet weren't able to
be seen so it's important when we have a
shortage of workforce
we make sure they can provide the most
care
that they can within the environment
available
we of course learned about this new
variance
of covert at the press conference
yesterday that pretty sobering news
conference that the prime minister said
that could be 70 more transmissible how
concerned are you
by these reports about the new variant
well actually we were concerned
at the time that the prime minister
announced the five-day relaxation
for christmas because the science told
us then that the virus was spreading
week on week it just did not follow the
science to relax the rules last
wednesday before the new variant was
announced
it was obvious that the infection was
spreading at a dangerous level the nhs
was
in a dangerous state and again the
science wasn't followed
when in fact we should have reversed the
christmas relaxation rules so in fact
whilst there is a new variant we didn't
need the new variant
to reverse these rules and the public
could of course have been given greater
notice
but there's no doubt it was the right
and necessary
uh a decision now the important point to
make is that whilst it is a new variant
the way in which you control spread of
the uh of the virus
including this new variant is exactly
the same it's about continuing
stringent measures to maintain physical
distancing of two meters and a more
stringent use of masks and also
hand washing that the same rules apply
and i think one of the problems we've
seen over the last few weeks
is that those rules have not been
adhered to in a stringent way
i think that will require the government
in the future to take more
uh action to make sure we don't see
scenes of crowded
streets in london with choppers because
that is the sort of way in which this
virus is spreading
you talking there about compliance about
people following the rules about the
scenes of crowded shopping streets
we of course saw those scenes of people
piling onto the trains didn't we
uh to try and leave london um when the
uh new restrictions came in what would
you
say to people who are thinking about
breaking the rules over the festive
period and you said that more
action from the government is needed
what do you mean by that
well what i mean is just making sure
there's crowd control and measures like
that i mean
i would just ask the question you
wouldn't see those scenes in east asian
countries that have managed pandemics
well in the past
that's what i'm talking about just
making sure that we have uh um
clear um arrangements so that people can
be
uh separated but i think it's more than
rules what what i think is really
important for the public to understand
is this is
an unforgiving virus and in fact you
know uh
whilst christmas uh is obviously going
to be ruined for many
uh the worst thing we could possibly be
doing is unknowingly
infected our loved ones infecting people
who are older in our families
who have underlying conditions only to
find that two weeks later in the new
year
they end up with serious illness in
hospital fighting for their lives
now that's not being alarmist that's
unfortunately the way this virus behaves
and the worst thing about this virus is
that one in three people may not even
know they're carrying the virus so you
may actually be passing it on
unknowingly so i think what the
important message for the public is
please understand this is a serious risk
and when we talk about the nhs and we
say you know let's reduce pressure on
the nhs please let's also remember
that the nhs isn't some remote
disconnected service
it's a service that any of us may need
to use
uh in if there's an urgent need and none
of us want to be
in a position where the health service
cannot be there for you when you need
because it's full it's at full capacity
and is then forcing you to be uh
transported to some more remote site
with all the delays that's involved
so please let's understand that saving
and protecting each other
and looking after each other is also as
important or really
will result in protecting our national
health service
it's been a pretty depressing weekend
for all of us
you know listening to you is extremely
sort of sobering as well
so let's talk about the light that there
is at the end of the tunnel which of
course is
the vaccine doctor's gp is expected to
play a really key
role in getting that vaccine out how
quickly do you think it can be rolled
out to the population
well you know we are working flat out
i'm a gp and my practice was one of the
first
in in the pilots to start uh on on
tuesday we survey a very large
um black and asian ethnic minority
population that have been hit really
hard
by this virus and many did not survive
uh during the
last year and so it was really i have to
say it was
positive it was very heartening to see
so many patients
uh come along and be vaccinated and of
course these were patients who were much
older who were most at risk and and
we've been working seven
days a week eight a.m to eight pm and in
fact many doctors staying there right
and through till about 10 o'clock at
night
so we are working flat out it will take
unfortunately
three to four months or enough of the
population
to be to be vaccinated that's what the
projections suggest
uh but what i i and therefore there is
light at the end of the tunnel
and so i hope people the public can
understand
and be patient just just just um you
know carry on being
responsible follow the rules and
measures
because you will be if all goes well in
a few months
be able to mix with family friends and
relatives so the vaccination program is
critical
but i'm actually very proud of the way
in which healthcare workers are
delivering this program
gp practices in the community many
hospital sites
but i think the olds have to be uh
recognized that to deliver this
in in this sort of short space of time
will mean huge amounts of staff time
and for some of those stuff they won't
be able to be carrying on
without with their normal roles uh but
but yes there is
light at the end of the tunnel at the
moment with the vaccine
it does feel like that's the one
difference the one shrink of light
compared to the last
uh wave the first wave that at least we
can see
an exit route now and dr chairman paul
thank you very much for being on the
program as always good to talk to you
thank you